while conservatives rally around
president Trump's America first message
leftists are trying out a new message of
their own this one care of Minnesota
Congress lady ilhan Omar it it's a
little bit weird for us politics but the
message is Somalia
first I'll translate says we as
Somalians we love each
other there are areas of friction that
led us to kill each other but in reality
we're an organized
Society brothers and
sisters people of the same
blood people who know they're Somalians
first Muslims second who protect one
another come to each other's Aid and the
of other Muslims to put pause right here
at least for the first part of what
she's
saying I kind of get it at least for the
first part of what she's saying she's
saying look we are brothers and sisters
literally that is true right you
people who are in your tribe your nation
your race your the I mean it when you
get down to the most basic unit it's
your family and you you care about your
family more than you care about other
people's families you care about your
family certainly more than you care
about your extended family right and
then you care about your extended family
more than you care about other people's
families and you care about your tribe
more than you care about other tribes
and you care about your community of
tribes more than you care about some
far-flung community of tribes and you
care about your nation more than you
care about other nations
that's just human nature there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with there being uh priorities of
Charity that's that's totally normal
that's been true for all of history she
says something weird here right she says
first I'm
Somalian then I'm a
Muslim Somalia is more important to me
than my religion very strange she keeps
going a couple days
ago many many Somalians have personally
called me to encourage me to speak to
the US government and to help Somalia
they wanted to know what the US
government will do my answer to
Somalians was the US government will
only do what Somalians in the US tell
them to
do they will do what we want and nothing
else they must follow our orders we
Somalians must have that confidence in
ourselves we live in the US pay taxes in
the US have a real voice us is a country
where one of your daughters is a
congressman to to represent your
interests Somalia will never be in
danger as long as I'm in the US
Congress the US would not dare to
support anyone against Somalia to steal
our land sleep and comfort knowing I'm
here to protect the interests of Somalia
from inside the US
system that's what I'm doing here in
Congress I'm here to protect Somalia
this is the best argument for
restricting immigration that I have
heard in years maybe that I've ever
heard this woman is not just admitting
that she had has a dual loyalty dual
loyalty is usually an accusation that
the Jews have to deal with that they
have a dual loyalty to two separate
Nations and to a lesser degree Catholics
are accused of it President Kennedy
certainly was though not quite as much
because the Vatican is not a nation
state in any modern sense or any
meaningful sense but ilhan here is
admitting something worse than either of
those
accusations she's not just saying she
has a split loyalty she's saying that
she is only loyal to Somalia full stop
and only after that only after her total
loyalty to Somalia is she even loyal to
Islam and at no point does she suggest
that she's loyal to America at all the
only reason she seems to like America is
in as much as she can use America to
benefit
Somalia so this woman should without
question be expelled from Congress over
this and probably she should be deported
of all of the outrageous statement ments
that this woman has made over the years
giggling at Osama Bin Laden alqaeda
remember that video or or enying against
the Jews or comparing the US Army to
jihadis this is on a whole other level a
sitting member of Congress is admitting
that she serves another Nation without
any loyalty whatsoever to our nation and
it's not all her
fault ilhan Omar's comments reveal a
major problem with mass migration sure
but ironically they also reveal a major
problem with nationalism I'm Michael
nlls this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show with welcome back to the show in
just a moment an Hathaway will debunk
the myth of heteronormativity I know
you're all on the edge of your seat for
that mind expanding lecture we'll get to
it in a moment first
though conservatives have adopted a
nationalist stance in recent years and
it's understandable because the libs are
trying to pet a liberal globalism and
that's just terrible and it takes away
our political rights and our sovereignty
and erases our borders and destroys our
way of life and and so I get it I I'm
practically a nationalist in as much as
nationalism is the way to oppose liberal
globalism but nationalism has problems
and ilhan Omar is actually demonstrating
some of those problems nationalism makes
an idol out of the
state it it nationalism don't forget is
not some perfect political Arrangement
nationalism is a relatively new
political arrangement for the world
order it comes out of 1648 out of the
Peace of West failure the whole point of
it is to end the 30 Years War and the
longer religious conflicts between
Catholics and Protestants that that
constituted the bloodiest uh Massacre
the the bloodiest bit of Warfare at that
time in European history and so they
come to this conclusion of nationalism
which says kuus Regio Aus religio in in
whose realm his religion and it said
that basically the the highest order of
human Affairs will be the nation state
and the king and and the civil
government and it was just practical it
was credential so that the Europeans
would stop killing each other but it it
didn't really resolve much of anything
at
all and I don't know at least for me I
don't view the the Civil Authority is
the
absolute most important thing in the
world deserving of all of my loyalty I I
would not say that Somalia is what I am
most loyal to I would not even say that
the United States is the entity that I'm
most loyal to I would say I'm most loyal
to God my identity is not first as an
American my identity is first as a
Christian and I'm very fortunate that I
live in a Christian country and even if
I didn't live in a Christian country I
would still have some loyalty to my
country because it is my country and
patriotism is an extension of filial
piety but I worship God I don't worship
Joe Biden certainly I don't even worship
Donald Trump I certainly prefer him to
Joe Biden but I don't worship him either
I don't put my my trust in
princes there's an order of things here
before nationalism people understood
that God came first there was in fact a
unified religion that unified the whole
civilization that we now call the West
freet tellingly we use the term the West
it used to be called Christendom because
it was unified by a single religion and
that fell apart in the 16th and 17th
centuries and now we're dealing with
nationalism the problem with nationalism
though is you got to pick one you ilhan
Omar cannot be an American truly if she
is still loyal to Somalia
but she still has loyalty to Somalia and
it was largely Somalian immigrants who
got her elected so I get that frankly
she jokes in Her speech she says haha I
can barely even speak this language I'm
so bad at speaking this language the
knock on her is she's not really a
traditional Somalian but she requires
that constituency and they're still
loyal to to their Old Country well you
can't have that in a national
system because for for every tiny bit
that they're loyal to some other country
they're not loyal to our country they're
just using our country instrumentally to
satisfy their own interests to the true
nation that holds their loyalty this is
why the only way that you can tolerate
immigration of any sort in under uh the
nation state World Order is if people
totally give up their
loyalty to the Nations they're leaving
but people just don't really do that
some groups have been more
successful the Irish the Irish basically
but I don't know even the the Irish will
wave the Irish flag every now and again
the Italians assimilated very very well
one mark of how well they assimilated is
you can't predict their politics based
on their their ethnicity you can't ba
you can't predict it based on whether or
not their name ends in a vowel you got
Nancy Pelosi on one hand you got anonin
Scalia on another you but still the
Italians you know they've got a little
bit of that pride of their Heritage and
certainly the more recent immigrants
have it in Spades a lot of them won't
even learn the English language have no
interest in learning the English
language and the country doesn't even
want to to assimilate them well then
you're not going to have a country for
time in Memorial going back to PL and
further back people have recognized that
migration poses a major challenge to the
country this is why it's the big issue
that's motivating conservative movements
all around the West right now all
throughout Europe and in the United
States but it's just a fact I can't even
blame Ela no more it is in human nature
to remain loyal to one's tribe and to
one's Heritage and you don't just erase
that overnight but that creates it's a
major major challenge for nationalism
and you couple that with mass migration
and no assimilation and what you're left
with is the destruction of your country
of of the country receiving the
immigrants as a political entity the
country ceases to be a coherent polity a
coherent political community and it
becomes it becomes nothing but a a
commercial Enterprise to satisfy the
unrelated personal Ambitions of of the
people who view it as nothing more than
a piggy bank
very sad very sad not good for the
future of the United States now one
thing that will be good for you are the
excellent shoes from Gravity defier
right now go to G defy.com use code
mk30 good Footwear is about more than
fashion what you wear on your feet
matters to your health your comfort your
well-being choosing Footwear that
provides support for your daily routine
is important now easier than ever thanks
to G defy shoes I love these shoes shoes
when they came in I said I hope these
aren't running shoes you know me I'm not
going to wear running shoes you think
I'm not the most athletic guy and then I
I take out the first pair they're not
running shoes they were beautiful Oxford
shoes with nice really comfy sols and
broing even which I really like in my
shoes and then I opened the next one and
they were running shoes but they're the
nicest looking most comfortable running
shoes I have ever seen you have got to
get G defy I am I I love them because
shoes are not just about fashion but
they're a little bit about fashion and
these just hit the mark on both I love
this company your feet deserve more than
just another pair of shoes right now use
code mk30 for 30 bucks off orders of 150
bucks or more G the letter G defi DF
y.com gy.com promo code mk30 for 30
bucks off your purchase of 150 bucks or
more experience the miracle that is g
defy where Comfort meets Innovation
speaking of
migration 69% of Voters side with Joe
side with sorry Texas over Joe Biden
this according to a new poll from Ras M
only 27% of Voters oppose Texas taking
action to prevent illegal
immigration uh this breaks down even
across constituencies that are not often
on the side of conservatives uh black
voters overwhelmingly vote Democrat and
yet according to this poll 51% of black
voters side with Texas only 32% of black
voters disagree two third of independent
side with Texas only 29% disagree this
is a huge losing issue for Democrat
which is exactly why Biden and the
Democrats are pushing this
terrible terrible immigration Bill
through the
Senate right now you may have heard
about it it's it's percolating in the
background the a bipartisan Committee of
civic-minded Republicans and Democrats
are getting together to pass a stinking
garbage heap of an immigration Bill
through the Senate and the only reason
it's coming up is because this issue is
has gotten so bad for Democrats among
groups that they need to win to maintain
their
power that they're trying to hang their
hat on anything I've said from the
beginning the bill is terrible the first
reason that this bill is terrible is
because the Democrats are currently in
violation of the law it's it's not as
though there's no law to deal with these
migrants oh we've never seen anything
like this we need to get together and
find a solution there are many many
immigration laws on the books that the
Democrats are intentionally not
enforcing and when the states are
enforcing them the Joe Biden and the
federal government come in and stop the
States from enforcing them so there can
be no negotiation with the Democrats
here the Democrats are proving
themselves every second of every day to
not be negotiating in good faith why
should I pass some new law about
immigration when I know for a fact today
Democrats are not enforcing the current
law on immigration I should have
absolutely no trust that the Democrats
will enforce anything they'll take the
goodies that we give them it'll be it'll
be like the Reagan amnesty all over
again they'll take the amnesty that we
give them and they will not give us any
of the enforcement in return as has
happened time and time
again fool me once shame on you fool me
twice fool me three times to quote
George W bush the point is you're not
going to fool me again that's that's
what we're looking at here it'd be one
thing if they had returned and were even
sort of pretending to enforce the law
they're not so there's no reason to
believe that but then what the bill
would do affirmatively is is awful too
absolutely awful this is being pushed by
the Oklahoma senator Jim Langford and
the Oklahoma GOP has actually just voted
to condemn and censure this supposedly
Republican senator because he's pushing
this bill that's great news I called for
that yesterday maybe they watched the
show I don't know I don't want to take
credit if it but you know may who knows
hey in any case glad it's happening
anyone who votes for this Rand ID
garbage heap of a bill deserves to be
thrown out of the Republican party I'm
I'm pretty broadminded as you know I try
to be fair to all the candidates and
different perspectives in the GOP I've
been very nice about the presidential
race this is just heinous this is this
is political suicide for the Republicans
Not only would voting for this be deeply
unjust it's political suicide you're
just trying to give the Democrats an
out the fact that we're even negotiating
this bill is giving Democrats an out
because if it fails as I hope it does
then the Democrats can say well
Republicans they wouldn't they wouldn't
come to a solution On the Border you got
a solution folks it's already on the
books Democrats are free to enforce the
law if they want they don't want to
because they want an invasion they just
want a py to blame it on and and Rhino
Republicans in the Senate seem more than
willing to be that py to to be the Court
Jester in the Kingdom of liberalism
which is what what these pseudo
conservatives always do in the bill what
this bill would do according to CBS News
the the agreement is expected to give
the executive branch a new legal
authority to effectively suspend asylum
in official ports of entry in between
official ports of Entry when migrant
Crossings surpass certain thresholds
okay hold on so the executive branch
will have a new legal authority to
suspend Asylum and the executive branch
already has authority to arrest people
who enter our country illegally the
executive branch already has authority
to streamline Asylum claims and Deport
people who who manifestly
don't qualify the executive branch has
this Authority already they could just
enforce the law no they would give them
new
ones and they could even suspend this
these Asylum claims once you hit certain
thresholds of Crossings okay what are
the
thresholds this is amaz this according
to CBS News not some right-wing
Outlet the uh the suspension of these of
the Border would be mandated after
average da migrant Crossings hit
5,000 over 7
Days 35,000 people cross in a week okay
all of a sudden now the president can
start to take a look maybe slow things
down a little bit 35,000 foreigners
Crossing into our country illegally or
8,500 in a single day 8500 people in a
day it's uh by my math 85,000 people in
10 days
and then by by my math that's 850,000
people in a 100 days so you talking
about in 100 days you're upwards of a
million people but there's what 300 uh
you know 365 some odd days in a
year so now you're looking at millions
and millions of these okay now we can
suspend it for a little bit but not for
too long not for too long there would
also be a limit on the number of days
each year the president could invoke
this Authority so you know he shuts it
down for a few days when you got at E5
500 people in a single day Crossing but
then eventually he he can't invoke it
anymore and they
cross are you kidding me this is the
Great Compromise oh thank you with
Republicans like this who needs
Democrats any Republican in the Senate
who votes for this
bill certainly should be
primaried should probably be thrown out
of the GOP it's it's so egregious on an
issue that is so fundamental even Beyond
migration it's just about the do we have
a rule of law or not
and on an issue that is such a political
winner for the current Republican
position I can't unless these people
just want to lose they want to get rid
of our borders flood our country and
just lose anything resembling
conservative governance I have no idea
what they are thinking speaking of tone
de leaders Karen Jean Pierre the
president's spokes lady uh has uh come
out she was on
MSNBC expressing the White House's
condolences over this horrific attack by
Iran backed militants on US troops what
I will say our deepest uh obviously our
deepest condolences uh go out and our
heartfelt condolences go out to the
families uh who lost uh three three
Brave uh three Brave uh three Brave of
three folks who are who are military
folks who are brave who are always
fighting who are fighting on behalf and
of uh this administration of the
American people obviously more so more
importantly uh we lost those Souls as
the president said yesterday when he was
South
Carolina this is about as bad a response
as any Administration could
muster military folks to stumble over
you can't say troops Fighters Warriors
service members military folks just
using colloquial leftist Community
activist
lingo who have fought on behalf of this
Administration
and she catches herself and she says and
and you know even more importantly for
our country it's a Freudian
slip this this is how they view the
military Biden and the Democrats they
view the military and law enforcement as
their as their personal police
force that's why Joe Biden scks the feds
on all of his enemies that's why he
sends the feds to go spy on Catholic
churches that's why he sends his feds to
go attack the pro- lifers knock on their
door arrest them in front of their seven
children for what for opposing
infanticide
peacefully that's why they go they don't
really seem keen on rounding up the the
George Floyd riers who burned the
country to the ground for eight months
they're n they're too busy for that but
the midwestern granny who took a selfie
in the capital they got to get her
better get her throw her in solitary for
40 41 months that that obviously is not
about enforcing the law they don't
enforce the law look at the board
this is about wielding the law against
political enemies look what they're
doing to Trump Prosecuting Trump trying
to throw him in prison for things that
virtually all of the Democrats have
already done and previous presidents
have done throwing Trump's trade adviser
a senior adviser to the president Peter
Navaro into prison for something that
Hunter Biden did Hunter Biden gets off
scotf free Navaro goes to jail for four
months and Navaro by the way as a senior
White House
adviser doesn't have to answer these
Congressional subpoenas
there executive privilege Hunter Biden
can't claim any of that doesn't matter
This Is How They view it so they say oh
yeah these people they serve they serve
the administration thank you so much for
serving Joe Biden and the
Democrats so in the midst of all of this
Decay and
Chaos we see the prospect of World War
III on the horizon and this has become a
theme of President Trump's campaign I am
the only candidate who can make this
promise to you I will prevent World War
II and we're very close to World War II
we're very close to World War I Trump is
known for his hyperbolic rhetoric for
making big big promises something maybe
doesn't necessarily keep every aspect of
the promises this one to me is the most
credible campaign promise that Trump can
possibly make and it looks very good on
him and when you want to look good you
got to check out jell right now go to
jus.com /n here is a great New Year's
resolution that you can actually keep
whether you have 3 minutes in the
morning or 30 minutes keep your face
wrinkle-free with genu cell introducing
gen 90 the new instant wrinkle treatment
from genus cell gen 90 instantly reduces
the appearance of wrinkles anywhere you
use it from around your eyes forehead
crows feet or laugh lines it starts
working in seconds genell says their gen
90 is two generations better than any
immediate effects product and years
ahead of the skincare Market the
technology is luxurious nourishing and
silk smooth through results are game
changers for you or your money back so
what are you waiting for make your fine
lines and wrinkles disappear with jus
cell you know I love this company the
founder is a Coptic Christian from Egypt
left for the American dream right now
our listeners will get not only over 70%
off J cell's most popular package but
also free shipping head to jus.com
kbls secure your gen 90 product before
they sell out jus.com
today
genucell.com
Trump says he is the only candidate who
can promise to stop World War
II you know I like Trump let's say you
hate
Trump can you really deny his foreign
policy
successes the man had the greatest
foreign policy probably of any president
in my lifetime George HW Bush did a good
job managing the first Iraq war and
managing the dismantling of the Soviet
Union he did a pretty good job at with
that so maybe but but Trump was
great Trump destroyed Isis Trump was
able to uh avoid getting the us too
bogged down in the Middle East unlike
both of his predecessors many of his
predecessors actually not just Obama and
Bush but Clinton Bush W to a lesser
degree
he seemed like a dove he was making
peace with the leader of North Korea for
goodness sakes on the one hand but then
on the other hand he'd take out Iran top
General so Iran does learns not to mess
with us look at what Iran is doing to us
now when we have weak
leadership the the only
president in over 20 years under whose
watch Vladimir Putin did not further
invade a sovereign country George George
W bush what happens Putin comes to power
right around the year 2000 George W bush
becomes President Putin invades
Georgia then Barack Obama becomes
President Putin invades Crimea then
Trump becomes president
crickets nothing then Biden becomes
President Putin launches the special
military operation further invades
Crimea and bogs us down in a war where
we're effectively a belligerent pretty
good stuff man Donald Trump brought
peace to the Middle East the guy got the
Abraham Accords he got Saudi Arabia to
the table with the state of Israel
pretty impressive and now we've got a
major war that's breaking out in the
Middle East that that we can't contain
and that and that has already taken
American lives because of the the
failure of the Biden Administration to
contain the war
of anything you want to you want to
accuse Trump of the guy this is a great
Campaign theme because it really cuts
through the noise it reminds me of
Ronald Reagan are you are you better now
than you were four years ago talking
about Jimmy Carter are you better Trump
could run on that and and with the
prospect of world war in front of us
that's a good theme now meanwhile the
libs are mocking Trump and they're
mocking Trump over things that they know
nothing about like this guy on SNL Trump
did have a slight stumble this week
while talking about Banks and he ined
uced an interesting new term called
debank we're also going to place strong
protections to stop Banks and Regulators
from trying to debank you they want to
debank you and we're going to
debank I don't know what the hell debank
means but he might have to take D
ambulance to see the
doctor this guy doesn't know what debank
means because liberals have never had to
deal with
it and because he doesn't read the news
and because the news he does read
doesn't tell him what's actually going
on in politics and because he didn't
even Google it and doesn't even he
didn't even read the Wikipedia page
about de
banking this is this is not Trump
sometimes makes up words like koffe but
this is not a word he made up this is a
real phenomenon and it's when liberals
wield their institutional political
power not necessarily in the government
but in the the supposedly private sector
that makes up all the rest of our life
and they wield their soft power in those
areas to deprive people of their bank
accounts that's what they do and it's
happened a lot you especially see this
in the United
Kingdom Trump or rather Nigel farage
who's the British Trump Nigel farage
leader of brexit he had his his bank
taken away from him ostensibly for
political reasons Stuart Campbell who's
a Scottish independence activist he had
his bank taken away and the reason
appears to be because he criticized
wokeness and
specifically Anglican vicer Reverend
Richard
fathergill he got his bank taken away
why it appears to be over the too and
you could be next these Libs have never
heard of this because they don't have to
deal with it there's no risk that that
you know the conservatives who control
the banks are going to take away their
their checking accounts that's never
going to happen there's no such thing
there's zero risk and they don't read
any of the news and the fake news media
that that you know constitute the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
NBC and ABC and all of the the outlets
that they read they just don't report on
this stuff because it's
unflattering amazing not not one writer
at one of the biggest shows at one of
the big TV networks had ever even heard
of a major political tactic wielded by
the Liberals against the
conservatives now speaking of trump
Haley the last person left in the GOP
race to oppose Trump has just come out
and weighed in on the egene Carroll
story eege Carroll is that New York
gossip columnist who a few years ago
came out and said that Trump raped her
in a a dressing room at Bergdorf Goodman
and when she was asked why she waited
you know 30 years or however long it was
to to bring this this up she didn't
really have a good answer and then after
a while she said she she suspects most
women fantasize about being raped and
then she didn't use the word rape she
said she said something like being
ravished or the whole thing was was
really odd she had a bizarre interview
with Anderson Cooper but the lady seems
a little kooky let's put it that way so
Nikki Haley was asked if she believes
that Trump sexually assaulted this woman
here's her answer the jury has now ruled
they have found him liable of sexual ual
abuse do you not trust the jury and
their findings Ambassador I absolutely
trust the jury and I think that they
made their decision based on the
evidence I just don't think that should
take him off the ballot I think the
American people will take him off the
ballot I think that's the best way to go
forward is not let him play the victim
let him play the loser that's what we
want him to do at the end of the day so
this is a principled enough answer from
Nikki she's saying yeah I trust the jury
I trust the court process even if the
courts have been obviously extremely
slanted against Trump in recent years
and then they're trying to get him over
anything and everything to keep him off
the ballot I trust the courts but even
if he's a
rapist that that doesn't mean you can
kick him off the ballot the PE the only
people who can kick him off the ballot
are the people when they vote for them
or not and that's a principled enough
answer that's the Constitutional
answer however this represents an
escalation in the primary battle between
Trump and Nikki Nikki Haley is a very
good politician and so she governed as a
relatively moderate Centrist governor of
South Carolina and then she got some
right-wing cred when she worked for
Trump as the UN Ambassador was very
popular in that role then she left she
got some more establishment cred uh then
she kind of turned on Trump then she end
essentially endorsed Trump again and
said she wouldn't run if he were running
and then she ran against him and so I
say all this to to say
she's she's pretty talented she's pretty
good at this and there was a world in
which maybe Trump would pick her to be
his running mate maybe or maybe he would
put her in the cabinet again I I don't
think that would be very
likely but now that's over we've now
entered a new phase of the primary such
as it is this is going to be scorched
Earth Nikki Haley just called Donald
Trump a rapist she said my opponent I
believe is a rapist I think he he raped
that woman or at the very least molested
or sexually assaulted her whatever the
whatever the euphemism is now in a
department store in burgdorf
Goodman how how does Donald Trump not
just put all of his Firepower on Nikki
Haley now how does this the only reason
that Trump would refrain from doing that
is because he just sees that she poses
no threat to him whatsoever so he's just
going to focus on Biden and he's going
to continue to walk away with the states
but that is a whole new level Nikki has
talk about picking her Lane I've said
from the the beginning Nikki was very
smart to pick the lane she's the
anti-trump candidate and and she's going
to consolidate that support in a way
that Ronda santis couldn't because he
was trying to play both lanes okay well
she picked her Lane and uh now I think
she's probably stuck in it for good
speaking of weird sex stuff and Hathaway
the actress
recently called to debunk the myth of
hetero CIS
normativity at the Human Rights Campaign
Gala that's the campaign with the equal
sign where it's these radical leftist
sex people who uh successfully lobbied
to abolish marriage and redefine it and
then started pushing a bunch of weird
stuff what I love most about this
community is the way you own the
alphabet
LGB t t q q i a a p no letter Left
Behind no for real what I love about
this community is the freedom the
freedom that comes with being yourself
all of yourself I love the energy the
activism the
generosity the light the
shade the
fun I love the dignity
that accompanies self-acceptance it is
important to acknowledge that with the
exception of being a cisgender male
everything about how I was born has put
me at the current center of a damaging
and widely accepted
myth that myth is that gayness orbits
around
straightness transgender orbits around
cisgender and that all Races orbit
around
whiteness yeah okay man so we're going
to debunk that
myth of
heteronormativity what does this woman
think normal
means nor normal has two meanings normal
means just the average just what is
common what people generally
do and and normal can also refer to a
norm or a standard that people fall
short of but they aim
at neither of those describe what Anne
hathway is talking about here there's
nothing like the
Dignity of accepting yourself you know
like when you're a man but you want to
be a woman so
[Music]
you it's that kind of self-acceptance
that is so dignified so dignified you
know going out there on the street
during the pride parade and wearing the
little leather chaps and smacking each
other around and getting on all fours
like that uh energy are under Joe Biden
the one who was stealing women's
clothing at the airport you know and
taking pictures of him with men on
collars and leashes and like leather
outfits it's just so
dignified you know if I had one word to
describe it I guess that word would
probably be dignified wouldn't
it reminds me of I think I quote him at
at this point every single day the late
great Norm McD Donald had a whole bit
which he did in San Francisco once about
the pride parade and he said you know
man you know I totally understand you
know if I if I had a kid who was gay and
everything I'd love that kid I saw you
saw some parents at a pride parade said
we're proud of our son he said I I love
I'd love the kid you know and uh I you
know I'd welcome that kid and i' hug him
and I don't know if I'd be proud exactly
I don't what's there to be proud of I
not a lot I would say not that's not
it's not the sort of thing you know you
get an award for that's not the sort of
thing you should if you have some weird
sex thing that you do you know I would
probably just encourage you to not do
that but if you're going to do it you
know just like kind of don't don't make
us all like see it and talk about it all
the time and have it in the middle of
the streets and have big Gallas and
invite Hollywood celebrities just like
kind of you know you don't you don't
need to you don't need to make
everything a big show but they do and
the reason that they do is because they
want to make that the norm in both
senses of the
word the way that most people be behave
these radical activists want to change
how most people behave that's why
they're putting this stuff in elementary
schools and even the standards that we
aim at that we all fall short of all the
time they want to change those too they
want to deny the objective moral order
they want to deny objective standards of
truth beauty and goodness and they want
to impose their own totally subjective
versions they want to make man into a
god a God who can reorder everything
according to his own fantasies doesn't
work out very well speaking of matters
of the heart Valentine's Day is coming
up fast Jeremy has the perfect gift to
surprise your better half whether you're
shopping for him or her Jeremy has a
bundle they will love from delicious
chocolate to smooth razors to the iconic
left of steers tumbler to celebrate
Jeremy is offering a 20% discount on all
Valentine's Day bundles but you have to
act fast because this offer is only here
for a limited time go to Jeremy rers.us
right now order your Valentine's Day
bundle before they're gone Jeremy's
Valentine's Day Sale the best way to
treat your Valentine and
yourself my favorite comment yesterday
is from Larry Gail nelli who says don't
worry the one in five are already
mailing in their straight ticket
Democrat ballot oh the one in five who
could be influenced by Taylor Swift yeah
probably though is there ever when was
the last time we had the biggest pop
star supporting a republican you know to
me that's just sort of baked in and
Taylor Swift is a big pop star we've had
big pop stars too and they just I don't
know Sinatra I think was maybe the last
one we had that was Republican and even
he was kind he was also buddies with
Kennedy so that's just kind of kind of
baked into it at this point I think
speaking of
abnormality an abortion Doula just gave
a lecture at the Catholic University of
America I was disinvited from a Catholic
university called the University of St
Thomas because I I don't believe
in I was just disinvited from the
University of St Thomas twice actually I
think uh because I believe in
Catholicism and Catholic teachings on
these questions the completely unchanged
consistent Catholic teaching of 2,000
years that's why they disinvited me and
now we have a Catholic University
inviting an abortion Doula what's an
abortion Doula an abortion D is like a
doula you know and a doula is just a
hippie term for a midwife Nanny you know
helper uh who will help help a woman as
she's giving birth to a baby and then in
the early days while the while the you
know newborn is is nice and fresh you
know and the mother's trying to sleep a
doula can help out then well an abortion
Doula is like that except for killing
the babies this abortion
Doula she spoke on her experiences
coaching coaching women through
delivering or aborting babies as well as
coaching pregnant men to deliver in what
she referred to as a seahorse birth uh
this is according to audio of the
lecture obtained by the daily signal she
also practices raiki which is an occult
practice that involves demons uh so she
does that Catholic University her name
is uh oh the woman who invited her
rather is Melissa Goldberg she is a
psychology lecturer at Catholic
University the du's name is Rachel
carbano sounds kind of voodoo and this
was for uh psychology 379 lifespan
development so one of the students a
nursing student named Filipe Avila said
it was really upsetting the fundamental
point is to understand human development
from conception to Natural death right
and they brought in someone who counsels
women to terminate life what's that
about it's
crazy it's actually destructive to their
you know if you go to Catholic
University you are supposed to be
receiving a Catholic Education
this contradicts the Catholic Education
this confuses the Catholic Education
bringing in this woman to speak harms
the education of students it it doesn't
really help it at
all other than perhaps to expose them to
just
how radically depraved the culture has
become outside of uh Catholic
thinking but the Libertarians aren't
going to like my suggestion here that
maybe CUA should cancel these kinds of
people what what the question you got to
ask yourself is what's the point of
education is the point of Education to
just hear everything man just open your
mind up you know to totally to
everything look I am the most canceled
speaker in America of 2023 per the uh
foundation for individual rights and
education okay I'm I speak I know what
I'm talking about here and I I I totally
defend the right of certain schools to
exclude certain speakers if if you send
your kid to communist Academy it's
probably not a good idea to invite me to
speak there you know the parents and the
kids are paying to be indoctrinated into
communism and to to have a a communist
ideology and I'm going to contradict
that probably not a not a great
idea now I I think I should still
probably go because communism is false
and there is such a thing as truth and
we can know about it and we should
prefer truth to
falsehood but that's what we're talking
about here I was talking to my friend
yuram honei the Israeli philosopher who
called my attention to a a phrase that
slipped into our culture that I think is
just so it didn't even occur to me how
bad this phrase is the phrase is
critical
thinking you know you hear it sometimes
Educators even on the right they'll say
we don't want to teach our students what
to think only how to think as if you
could do one without the other as if as
if you could ever know how to think
without knowing specific things to think
you know 2 plus 2 for murder is bad
whatever but but he said this phrase
critical thinking why why do we have all
this critical thinking whatever happened
to constructive thinking constructive
thinking is when you learn a thing and
then you build on that and then you
build on that you build on that and
eventually you have an edifice of
knowledge before you critical thinking
just pokes holes in everything seems
related to critical theory critical
studies just debunking and
deconstructing and tearing everything
down to the point that by the time you
graduate you're dumber than when you
went in there there was a survey came
out a while ago now I think from isi
2007 that that showed that students at
Elite colleges in America got Dumber the
longer they attended that that
graduating seniors knew less about
history and Civics than incoming
freshmen that's critical thinking for
you that's deconstruction I like
constructive thinking and I like Banning
speakers who are harmful to
education now speaking of norms and
women Alissa Milano Lissa Milano very
excitable
left-wing figure and actress she just
took to Twitter to beg her many
followers for money for her kids
baseball team tweets out go fund me my
son's baseball team is raising money for
their Cooperstown trip you know Baseball
Hall of Fame any amount would be so
greatly appreciated you can read more
about the team and make a donation here
okay got got almost 12 million
views it's a bad look it's a bad look
because Alyssa Milano is really really
rich unless she's completely mishandled
her money Alysa Milano has made millions
and millions for tens of millions of
dollars over the course of her life and
she doesn't need to be begging her
followers to chip in a penny this not a
good look this is annoying when people
do this around the office you know it's
luckily no one does it here because the
average age of this company is like 12
but you know I remember this what
happened in my mother's office as a kid
I all rent the schools say hey sell
wrapping paper or hey sell this thing or
that thing to raise money for a field
trip and then you give it to your
parents and your parents go around the
office and they say would you mind
donating to my school's my kids school
thing and it just it never ends okay
what's bad enough when it's just a
regular middle class person in an office
Alyssa Milano is a very famous very
wealthy Hollywood celebrity not a good
look very famous very wealthy Hollywood
celebrities should be donating not just
to their kids baseball teams but to
other to other um Charities as well I
don't know what her charitable giving
looks like but it's really bad for
wealthy powerful people to be spending
ranko fundme it represents a fundamental
shift in our
country where to quote John Kennedy
people no longer ask what they can do
for their country instead they ask what
their country can do for them they they
treat their country just like ilhan Omar
treats their country it's just an
instrument for one's personal interests
and and uh other loyalties and other
sympathies it's not good both the left
and the right have lost a conception of
the common good and and uh of of giving
of themselves to their Community to even
have a community to which they can be
loyal we deny that in our age of radical
individualism and and radical liberalism
and and but if you don't do that if you
don't give to your community then you're
not going to be able to construct
anything you're not going to be able to
build the only thing you're going to
leave to your children is an inheritance
of of debt and a country in
rubble got to change that thinking okay
there's no member block because I'm
flying out to La La Land wish me luck
I've got some fun stuff coming up this
week going to be filming some stuff for
prageru you know I have a show over
there and five minute videos and
then as important I've got a cool
podcast that I'm going on I will let you
know more about that as it approaches
I'm Michael N this is the Michael N show
see you
tomorrow
[Music]
a